Okay Michael. So, are you ready to give me a ranking
>> Yes, yes, I think I am.
>> Okay, well, if you give me a ranking then.
>> So, did you say one was the best.
>> One is the best and three is the least best. Alright, so I
am really excited about the third cloud
structure. The third attribute to be split
on. Because, what it does. Is it takes all our x's and o's That
need to have different labels and it
puts them into two different buckets. One where
they all get to be red x's and the other where they all get to
be green o's. So I would say the far right one is ranked number one.
>> I would agree with you and in fact I would say that infact we're done.
>> Yeah, it's perfect.
>> It is perfect, agreed. One is perfect. Or 3
is perfect in this case, because I gave it a one.
>> Alright, so then, I think the worst one is also
easy to pick, because if you look at the middle attribute,
the attribute that's shown in the middle, we take all the data, and we put
it all on the left. So we really have just kicked the can down the
road a little bit. There's nothing. That
this attribute splitting has done. So, I would
call that the worst possible thing you could
do. Which is to basically to do nothing.
>> No, I think that's right. and, in fact, it really is doing nothing.
>> Right.
>> Okay. So
what about the first attribute?
>> So, I'm going to put that at, you know,
if the first one is too hot and the middle
one is too cold, I would say this one is,
wait, no, no. [LAUGH] I was going down the Goldilocks
path. So, so this one is sort of in between.
In that it splits things so you have smaller sets
of data to deal with, but it hasn't really improved
our ability to tell the reds and the greens apart.
So in fact, I'd almost want to put this as three also but I'll put it as two.
>> Okay. I think an argument could be making it three. An argument could be
made for making it two. Your point is actually pretty good, right? We have eight
red things and eight green things up
here. And the kind of distribution between them,
sort of half red and, half red x's,
half green o's, we have the same distribution
after we go through this attribute here. So it does some
splitting, but it's still, well you still end up with half
red, half green, half x, half o. So, that's not a
lot of help, but it's certainly better than doing absolutely nothing.
>> Well is it though? I mean, it seems
it could also be the case. That what we've done
is that we're now splitting on that has provided
no valid information, and therefore can only contribute to overfitting.
>> That's that's a good point. That's a
good point. So, do you want to change your answer
to three?
>> I don't know, what did you want the answer to be? It seems
to me that the first one and the second one are just plain bad.
>> They are just plain bad. The question
is whether one is, more bad than the other.
>> I, I don't know. I don't know how to judge.
>> Well I'll tell you, I would accept
either two or a three as an answer here.
I think you can make an argument either
way. And I think you actually made both arguments.
>> That's very nice of you.
>> So.
>> Thank you.
>> You're very welcome. So this is perfect. This
is the House of Representatives and this is the Senate.
>> [LAUGH] What do you mean they're? Oh. So, there you go. Okay.
>> [LAUGH] Not exactly sure what you mean,
but it seems somehow denigrating to our political system.
>> It is not at all denigrating. It is,
it is, I would call it incisive political satire.